the primary goal of every story is to
elicit emotion elicit emotion okay and
if it's too stale let's suppose the
writer thinks that there's emotion that
it's going somewhere but the reader is
not getting the emotion that the writer
intends where's the breakdown there the
the breakdown is definitely with the
writer you know it's not it's not an
audience's or a readers job to feel
something that's something you have to
elicit so it means you haven't created
sufficient conflict in your story to
elicit emotion or you haven't created a
premise a concept of a story you haven't
structured in such a way that that
conflict makes any sense or it can be
mostly involving because you've given
the reader nothing to root for or you
haven't created empathy with the hero or
whatever it might be but it's your job
to elicit emotion the emotion has to
come naturally from the reader an
audience because of what they're what
you've done they have to be
participating in the story you've
created that's why for example empathy
is so important for the hero for you to
create for your hero because a story is
a participatory experience for the
audience of a listener of the reader we
become that character we want to
experience the emotion as they do it's
not we don't go to the movies because
it's interesting to watch people do
things it's emotional for us to get to
do them we become Jason Bourne we become
rose as she falls in love with Jack and
is on the Titanic we become the woman
who the astronaut who's out in space and
gravity we are a part of it we're
participating in the action in the
events of that story but we have no
basis no way to get into the story
if we don't on a subconscious level
become the hero of that story and that's
what the empathy and identification you
create at the beginning is going to do
so if you've created a story with an
empathetic hero's that we participate
giving them a clear goal and created
enough logical believe
well obstacles still overcome then the
emotion will grow organically out of
your audience because they're in it and
you've created the conflict that will do
that what about the writer that just
puts incident after incident of
conflicts but then the story just falls
flat what's it missing well it could be
missing any number of things but as I
said earlier to me all roads lead to the
outer motivation and so if all you're
doing is stringing together obstacles to
overcome and there's a very similar
mistake and that is people who think
comedy is one funny thing after another
happening that's not what that's not
what a story is a story is the sequence
of events experienced by a hero who's
pursuing a very specific goal so if
you're just throwing one obstacle after
another but we don't care about the hero
or the hero it's not clear why the hero
is doing this or what they're trying to
achieve or if those obstacles are
illogical or if the pace of the story
lags or if everything is at a very high
level of emotion and you're not creating
sort of peaks and valleys to the
emotional level so you have big moments
and quiet moments and moments of
connection and moments of separation and
so on there are all those things you've
got to do in addition to throwing a
bunch of you know car chases and fight
scenes up on the screen which many
people have tried and those movies don't
succeed if if it's just car chases and
fight scenes it's just you know it's
just a series of videos really but it's
not a story or a movie that are people
are going to be involved in so there has
to be a resting point it's pusat peaks
and valleys so at some point it has to
kind of drop well it has to alternate
yeah it's it's not a resting point as if
you stay there forever but you don't
it's like in a comedy you don't want
joke Tok Tok Tok Tok there's got to be a
serious moment or two and and look at
any great comedy you look at it even any
decent comedy and there's going to be
something very funny but there's going
to be something touching or sad or
romantic or there's going to be a deeper
connection between the characters or
there's going to be something more
exciting or there's going to be
something softer you want to vary the
peaks and valleys the emotional level
and and pitch of the story as we go
steadily toward the finish line that the
hero is trying to reach so the obstacles
need to get bigger they need to come
closer together as it moves forward so
the pace will accelerate but if there's
only obstacles one right after the other
with no chance to catch our breath no
chance to anticipate what might be
coming no chance to explain what's going
on and no chance to get closer or deeper
into the characters it's going to be a
very very shallow story with very
limited emotional involvement or appeal
you